يتعهد هذا الشيخ بتجهيز موائد افطار رمضان
منذ 45 عاما
يحضر الحاج عبد الله نفسه لاعلان الافطار
بالطريقه التقليديه
انه تقليد يمارس في مسجد كمبونغ هولو منذ
بنائه قبل اربعه قرون على نفقه تاجر صيني
بمدينه ملقا الماليزيه
يتولى اهالي المسجد خدمه الصائمين خلافا
لكثير من المساجد الماليزيه التي تنظم
انشطه التكافل الاجتماعي فيها مؤسسات
خيريه
يتولى اهل المسجد وانا منهم جميع الانشطه
كالتحضير لطعام الافطار وصلاه الجمعه
وبدون المتطوعين لا نستطيع تقديم طعام
الافطار لمئتي شخص يوميا فهذا العمل يحتاج
الى تعاون وتنظيم
[موسيقى]
تنبه شباب كرويون الى غياب اصوات العزف
هذه عن ازقه كراهم
[موسيقى]
فهذا المزمار لم يسمع في اوقات السحور منذ
سنوات
وشاركهم الشيوخ في تعليم الصغار عمل
المسحرات
هذه اداه التنبيه المعتاده لوقت السحور
عندنا وقد استهلت فكره احياء عمل
المساحرات شباب القريه وعندما نبدا النداء
للسحور يخرج بعض اهل القريه لمشاهدتنا
ويقدمون لنا الطعام والشراب احيانا
ويسالون متى نعود ثانيه
[موسيقى]
فيه المسيرات الليليه
فهم يخشون اندثار هذه الاهازيج
لقد حولوا مهمه المسحرات الى مهرجان جماعي
لاحياء تقاليد رمضان
وقد تنوعت وسائل التنبيه الحديثه وتغير
معها نمط حياه كثير من الناس
بالنسبه لهؤلاء الشباب القرويين
الماليزيين المسحراتي ليس مجرده تنبيه
للصائمين النائمين بحلول وقت السحور انه
تقليد متجدد في هذه الربوع تلهج فيه
الاصوات بنفحات ايمانيه وهم يجتهدون
للحفاظ على تقاليدهم باساليب جديده سامر
علاوي الجزيره ولايه ملقا